I simply made up the anisotropic function out of my head. However, there's
considerable research about how to capture BRDFs from materials, and how to
make functions to compactly represent them. BRDFs are just the start. There's
also the BSDF, the Beet Sugar Development Foundation. We're more interested in
the Bi-Directional Scattering Distribution Function. This type of function
captures both how light reflects from and transmits through material. There's
also the BSSRDFs which stands for Bidirectional Surface Scattering Reflectance
Distribution Function. Say that one three times fast. This function is
important for materials like marble and milk. For these materials in
particular, the light enters one location on the surface, bounces around inside
the material, and comes out somewhere nearby. One other extremely important
material that has this sort of scattering is skin. Getting skin to look good
for interactive rendering can be quite involved. But the results are more
convincing than using some simple reflection model. See the additional course
materials for more information. That said, the key factor here is scale. The
effect of subsurface scattering lessens as the viewer's distance from the
object increases. Close up, a photon might exit at a location that's a fair
number of pixels away from where it entered the surface. From farther away,
they may be no change in pixel location. In fact the diffuse component for all
non-metallic materials comes from subsurface scattering. It's just that in many
cases this scattering is over an imperceptably small distance. Metals
themselves are essentially all specular. Let me say that again, because all
this time we've been living a lie. Metallic objects have no lambertian diffuse
term. Well, not a lie, I just like being dramatic. Really, diffuse is simply an
approximation of which we should be aware. Using it's fine, even high-quality
applications do so. It's quick to compute and looks plausible. In reality,
metals can indeed be given a roughened surface to give them a glossier, diffuse
look. So, a diffuse term is fine. However, on a an atomic level, metallic
objects have a free floating soup of electrons on the surface which absorbs and
reemits incoming photons. If your surface represents a shiny metal, you
probably don't want a diffuse term. Insulators have a diffuse term because the
photons undergo subsurface scattering. Most of the time the entry and exit
points are so close together it doesn't matter. But the direction of exit
certainly does. Materials such as that in an unglazed clay pot, concrete, and
even the moon itself, are rough enough that the lambertian reflection model
doesn't capture them fully. This again turns out to be a matter of scale,
having to do with the relationship of surface roughness with subsurface
scattering. Admittedly, trying to capture all of these effects leads to a lot
of work and possibly inefficient shaders. These subsurface scattering
renderings are from 3D Studio Max and rendered offline, not at interactive
rates. The main thing is to realize we don't have to stick with illumination
models from the 1970's because of inertia or ignorance. Using reflection models
based on how the real world works has a number of advantages. First and
foremost, if everything is properly modeled, your virtual world acts like the
real world. Change lighting conditions, and you don't have to tweak material
settings to look good. For design software, this assurance can mean that you
can trust what you see on the screen to have some relationship to what you
manufacture. Physically based rendering is also a great help to virtual world
content creators, such as game and film makers. It's a time saver to have
predictable illumination models, as the artist does not have to learn obscure
sliders that have no real world counterparts. It's vastly reassuring, knowing
that materials won't show some glitch from a certain angle, and knowing that
lighting can be changed without destroying the sense of realism. Rather than
limit creativity, a well-designed system makes for a more productive and
unrestrictive environment.